I think you're a real talent a real good
comedy mine but I mean you really do
maybe not as Extreme as Knoxville but
you really do put yourself in danger
and I wonder like do you think seriously
that you have a death wish I mean it
seem like you enjoyed how could you
laugh at that I mean well it's because
it's because I I hang out with Knoxville
and Sasha Baron Cohen now and those guys
have such a larger Death Wish than me
like I seriously think Sasha wants to be
like assassinated by a politician and I
think I think Knoxville wants to be
killed by a wild animal so like they
those guys they're my heroes you know
they've raised the bar so high that like
any little thing I do I'm like well I
didn't just get a brain hemorrhage from
a bull so they they've skewed my reality
of safety when Johnny was on our show he
told me this story when he tried to
break into your house and then you
called the police oh yeah I was toilet
paper in his house and uh he kept
yelling out to he kept yelling out the
door I've called the cops I've called
the cops I have a gun I have a gun and
I'm just I'm doubled over what was that
[__] deal from your end of it for
Christmas I was gonna go home visit my
family
and I got covered so I was like [__] and
like I was already vaccinated so like it
wasn't too it wasn't kicking my ass too
bad I had a couple days of brain fog and
sickness but then
the day three I didn't feel sick at all
so I'm just like at home
I was eating mushrooms I Never Smoke
Weed I was smoking pot I was making
[__] eggnog doing whippets watching
Bad Santa were you alone or you had no
I'm alone I had coveted I had to
quarantine so I'm getting hammered at my
house by myself and then I see Knoxville
with this like I didn't know it's him at
first right yeah I'm just sitting in my
house and I see somebody with hear that
Andy Warhol wig on so I don't even
recognize them and he's toilet papering
my house and I I have a gun next to my
bed so I open the window and I'm like I
got a gun I got a garden called the
police I'm gonna shoot you and the guy's
cracking up and that's making me more
mad I just hear him laughing and I see
him filming me I don't know it's
Knoxville he's like filming me on his
iPhone he's laughing I was like I got a
[__] God I'll [__] Calio I'm
calling the police the police are on
their way my alarm system's going on
and then he pressing his face up against
my window
and I'm like [__] Knoxville I was
like I was about to shoot you and he
goes right that would have been so fun
and we're about to do a jackass was
about to Premiere he'd be like what
better press would that have been if you
had shot me
and I went to the hospital or died right
before the movie comes out and I'm like
you're out of your [__] mind I just
don't get you guys one time I was
drinking at a bar with Knoxville he's
like crazy 24 7. I'm drinking at a bar
with him I'm with Jeff Tremaine I'm
standing up it's a tiki bar
I'm standing I'm trying to get the
bartender's attention I have sandals on
and my left foot feels like it's like in
the greatest pain out of nowhere I think
I'm having the crazy allergic reaction I
looked down at my feet Knoxville has a
bottle of 151 rum and he poured it all
over my left foot and he's got a thing
of matches and he set my left foot on
fire I'm at the bar and my foot is like
engulfed in flames I'm like ah I'm
trying to step it out I'm stepping in
more rum
there's no camera right it's not a
camera no camera it was just like a
Tuesday night just a bunch of friends I
took my crew out we were drinking and
then Knoxville goes that was an accident
that's so great